welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it looks like
fans of the MCU are heading into the
multiverse of madness with the
announcement of Doctor Strange -
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the upcoming film as well as the
secret meaning behind its title there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
don't want anything from the film
potentially room for you then I highly
suggest that you turn off now there's
also some spoilers in relation to Spider
Man part from home so definitely skip
this video if you haven't had a chance
to watch it yet without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
my breakdown of Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness okay so firstly
the film was announced at San Diego
comic-con 2019 at the Marvel phase 4
panel in Hall H Kevin Feige who hosted
the panel stated that the film would
once more be directed by Scott
Derrickson who was at the helm of the
first film and it will be released on
May 7th 2021 the movie is currently
being promoted as Marvel's first ever
horror film and it's also the first
movie in the slay that will directly
tackle the multiverse whilst the
multiverse was a huge plot device and
spider-man far from home with Mysterio
claiming to be from another earth this
was revealed to be a lie however at the
panel Kevin Feige himself said that this
doesn't mean that it does not exist the
film is set to tie directly into the
events of the upcoming Disney Plus show
one division which will center around
the relationship of Scarlet Witch and
vision who it seems will be resurrected
in the film after his death in infinity
war but we haven't had any confirmation
of the plot or film there are rumors
that the evil entity nightmare is said
to be the big bad of the film with
casting directors currently deciding
between Christian Bale and Matt Smith
nightmare is the ruler of the dream
dimension which is an area that humans
are brought during their sleep to be
tormented and tortured though nightmare
is predominantly a villain he and
strange you've had to team up in the
past to save the world so there are
definitely a lot of dynamics that can
meet
by the appearance of the new character
the film is also set to pick up on the
post credit scene of dr. strange in
which more dough started his mission of
destroying sorcerers the fact that there
are less wizards in the world has been
pointed out in infinity war when strange
wasn't really joined by any others when
fighting the forces of Thanos and later
an end game when one arrived with his
forces and strange asked is this all you
could get this kinda cements that Mordor
has been successful in his mission of
murdering so many and whilst wang who
took over the position of sorceress
supreme and strange absence probably
thought that this was due to the snap
the fact that they are not there at the
end confirms this therefore i think the
film will send her around strange
discovering the multiverse and nightmare
along with it and accidentally
introducing him to our world which
begins to send people to the brink of
insanity strange we'll have to call on
others such as Scarlet Witch of vision
and Mordor to take him down and thus
their alliance will be formed the
madness in the title could refer to the
fact that in the comics nightmare
requires humans to dream in order for
him to live without them traveling to
his dimension he's unable to feed and
therefore exists juxtaposing this if
humans are unable to dream or sleep then
they will eventually go insane and I
think that the film will focus heavily
on strange trying to return nightmare to
his home in order to save humanity from
collapsing in on itself so what is the
title itself actually a reference to
well strange is no stranger to horror in
the comic books and it appears that in
the multiverse of madness is a nod to
the infamous HP Lovecraft novel titled
at the mountains of madness throughout
his long and rich history strangers
tackled many of the creatures that
Lovecraft created due to his work now
being out of copyright and it appears
that this film will take a similar form
at the mountains of madness follows an
expedition group that discover uncharted
areas of Antarctica and unwittingly
unearth a long-forgotten civilization
and an alien race that exists there the
book went on to inspire classic horrors
like the thing and there's a wealth of
potential to pull from here if Marvel
decide to use elements of it the film
does sound incredible from the tidbits
that we know so far and it's great to
see that the MCU is slowly drifting away
from their formula to discover new areas
in the
universe that will totally shift the
balance of the films going forward I
can't wait to see what in the multiverse
of madness is like and needless to say
I'm really excited for the film's
release in 2021
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this announcement and what you're
most excited to see in the movie comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video that make sure you check out
my breakdown of the Black Widow footage
that was shown at San Diego comic-con
which would be linked at the end we go
over the scenes bit by bit so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more I'll leave that linked
at the end and hopefully I'll see you
over there after this I also just want
to let you know that we're giving away a
free copy of Avengers and gave to one
look you win on blu-ray and all you have
to do is like this video make sure that
you subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on Doctor Strange 2 in the
comment section below the one will be
chosen at random on August the 10th and
the blu-ray will be shipped out from
then to ever get surprise it's the best
of luck to everyone who takes part this
is a channel for people who are super
into superheroes so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you